our car tester tells us about the new
facelift of the Toyota Auris there are
been upgrades to the exterior design the
engines and the driver assistance
systems her test car has a 1.6 liter
diesel engine which has replaced the
2-liter version she's going to show us
exactly what the new iris has to offer
since 2009 the ours has been available
as a hybrid alongside the two
conventional models Toyota has improved
all three engine types and has made the
standard engines more efficient by
decreasing their size
this model consumes on average around 4
litres of fuel per 100 kilometers with
carbon dioxide emissions of 104 grams
per kilometer the new ours will come
onto the market in September the prices
aren't set yet but will be based on
previous versions Tina says the new 1.6
diesel versions high power and torque
give it a very fast feel she finds the
steering wheel really fits your hands
and changing manually between the six
years is very smooth and comfortable
Toyota has given the exterior new
flowing lines the silver trim sweeps
elegantly from one headlight to the
other
the back of the car is more angular
Toyota works in several sites to meet
the desires of their different European
customers Thomas Hyde brink works for
Toyota he tells us about its development
and research center in Brussels and its
design center in France the ours is
manufactured in the UK and hybrid and
conventional models
Thomas notes that this is a European
product made for Europe and even is
imported to Asia the station wagon and
5-door hatchback models look the same
from the front but had their own
distinct rear design
we're trying out the assistant systems
at this test site in Brussels it's worth
testing the emergency functions
beforehand for your own peace of mind
enos is testing the pre-collision system
which is designed to prevent fender
benders when driving in the city she's
going at 30 kilometres per hour towards
an obstacle and she's going to pretend
she's not paying attention the system
applies the brakes to stop her crashing
and this braking system works even if
your foot is still on the accelerator
our tester finds it strange relying on
the system and also thinks the noises
and abrupt breaking are a bit unnerving
but once you know that it works and you
trust it
she thinks it's really a comforting and
useful feature the technology for this
system is fitted around the rear mirror
the ours collects the necessary
information using a camera and a laser
sensor these are also used for the full
beam assistant and the lane departure
warning system it also recognizes
traffic signs and communicates them to
the driver
eNOS says the cars thin pillars have
improved visibility and thus safety tayo
des has spruced up the interior as well
the display in the central console now
resembles a tablet and can be operated
via touchscreen eNOS is impressed all
around with the new Toyota Auris she
likes the design of the 3d rear lights
and the assistant systems which you can
add on for 550 euros in Germany she
thinks they'll make everyday city
driving much safer
you